The future of manufacturing is
gonna be this convergence of
the digitization of technology,
with what's needed in manufacturing.
And that's going to create
greater productivity.
It's gonna create the ability to customize
products and do it very quickly.
>> Robotics up until now have been caged,
they've been isolated.
I think in the future of robotics, they're
going to expand out in processes not only
within facilities, but between facilities.
>> We're looking for
collaborative technologies for robots and
things to operate
together to conduct these
challenges within
the manufacturing environment.
The ARM Institute's
mission is to bring back
more manufacturing to the United States,
and
also to grow new types of
manufacturing in the United States.
Carnegie Mellon has already demonstrated
an extraordinary leadership in
helping to shape the agenda for
manufacturing.
>> Carnegie Mellon is a critical
part of our efforts to develop and
promote an advanced manufacturing and
robotics sector in our community.
We believe we can be the test bed for
the rest of the country.
>> Having Carnegie Mellon
leading the arm and
technology maturation generates
incredible job growth within Pittsburgh.
You're already starting to
see the inflow of talent.
>> It puts us right in the middle of
basic research with academia, and
it's the best in the world
that we can have access to.
And it would be difficult to find and
have access to that on our own.
>> It's taken innovation all
the way through its research and
engineering phases to product.
>> We believe in the mission, which is to
use automation and robotic technologies,
artificial intelligence to make
manufacture in the U.S. more competitive.
>> Carnegie Mellon has already, and
will continue, to play a very strong role.
They have some of the world's leading
experts in the types of technologies
that are driving manufacturing success.
>> We're going to continue to draw more
people that want to build a company
around robotics technology.
>> The future's here now.
>> We're very excited about the fact that
Carnegie Mellon and the ARM institute have
combined together to enable this first
building at the Hazelwood Green site.
>> This is a really exciting time to
be in manufacturing in the US and
especially here in the Pittsburgh region.
It's really exciting to be
part of this revolution.
[MUSIC]